To be a futurist you have to declare
yourself to be a futurist
within some community of futuristic practice.
It's not a thing you can do all by yourself.
So for instance to be a science-fiction brand of futurist
I have to publish some science fiction.
If I just write my weird musings about the future
in my private diary nobody's ever gonna know.
It's gonna make zero difference.
I have to participate in some kind of publishing system.
I have to be involved in the literary world in some way.
And I have to communicate.
Otherwise I'm the Crusoe guy,
telling himself bar stories alone.
So for me to write a novel about the future though
somebody has to invent the literary concept
of writing a novel with a setting which is in the future.
And that did not happen until the 1600s.
I mean people were writing stories for millennia
before anybody thought
'why don't I just set it in the time to come'
somebody had to and undertake this literary invention.
It had never occurred to anybody.
It was a kind of Copernican breakthrough, it's like
'wait, I could set it in the past
or I could set in today...
or I could like set it in the future!'
And this happened like 10 or 12 times by different authors before anybody really caught on.
And thought you know this could work.
It was independently invented by a large variety
of Robinson Crusoe-style
"Ur-science fiction" writers who
wrote these eccentric things and nobody picked it up
nobody went anywhere with it.
There was no futuristic community of practice.
They would just write it and have it go on.
It was impossible at that time to be futuristic
in the science fictional way.
You just couldn't do it.
Until people had a discourse of scientific romance.
A way to talk about it.
And they had a publishing structure, and
a distribution structure, and an audience,
and some literary cliques.
And also some critical responses.
And before those things were invented you just
couldn't do it. It was just beyond the capacity.
But after they were invented, then
you could be a science fictional futurist.
Mostly through declaring to other people
that you were one.
And they had to hear you.
And they had to agree.
They had to validate your declaration.
It's like, yeah, you're one of us.
Here's your Hugo Award. You know, whatever.
And you could join the
Science Fiction Writers of America.
But without them, you're the Robinson Crusoe guy
drawing weird diagrams.